Please welcome Nacho and Bobby Flay.
(audience applauding)
Hi Drew.
Bobby, I wish you were in the studio with me.
I know, it looks so much fun there.
I mean, all of those puppies and kittens, it's amazing.
I mean, I know you're an animal lover
and I can't wait to talk about Nacho's new food line,
which by the way, where's Nacho?
He's right here.
He's hanging out by his food.
Do you see him?
Gosh, he really knows how to pose and do it for the thing.
(Bobby laughing)
So guess who I brought for Nacho today?
This is my rescue cat, Peach.
I think I've sent you pictures
of Peach specifically for Nacho.
So cute, amazing.
I kind of feel like they should date.
She's single, Peach.
(audience wooing)
All right, well I mean, I think
it could be an online dating success here.
What do you think?
I'm feeling it.
I've always thought these two should get together.
I like it.
Nacho is the coolest cat ever.
You have restaurants named after Nacho.
You have an amazing food line that's coming out
which by the way, I am immediately stealing from the set.
You know, I get to feed people every day of my life,
either through my restaurants or through my books,
my TV shows, whatever.
You know and Nacho is clearly so incredibly important to me.
And he basically whispered in my ear
during one of our conversations,
he was like, "Listen, you feed everybody else,
"you know, what about us?"
I have another cat named Stella who's his sister.
And it really got me thinking
that we should really you know,
together with Nacho's inspiration,
really come up with a cat food
that cats can really get behind.
Really,truly a cat-focused cat food.
So you know, using some of the things that I bring
to the table in terms of, you know, feeding humans.
Things like one of his one of his secret ingredients
is bone broth, obviously using really amazing proteins
and ingredients that are very well-balanced diet.
I mean, that's really the key.
It was something that we really thought about.
And this is a family business.
This is from scratch and it's just launching this week.
And thank you so much for talking about it.
I'm so excited, I'm gonna be a loyal customer.
Listen, you're one of the most famous chefs in the world.
In fact, you just got a star on the Hollywood Walk of Fame.
(audience applauding)
Yeah that was an amazing moment.
First chef to get it on, to get a star
on the Hollywood walk of Fame.
And you know, that was an amazing moment.
We were very, very cool.
And it's so well earned.
You really changed the game.
(upbeat music)